hey there I'm Jason Goss and you're
listening to think again a big fink
podcast since 2008 the big think has
been chairing big ideas from some of the
most creative thinkers around on the
think again podcast we step outside of
our comfort zone surprising our guests
and me your host with unexpected
conversation starters from big things
interview archives ideas that we didn't
necessarily come here prepared to
discuss today I'm very very happy to be
sitting here with Jim Gaffigan he is a
Grammy nominated comedian and the New
York Times bestselling author of dad is
fat and other books and he's about to
launch the second season of his semi
fictitious TV show the Jim Gaffigan show
which premieres with two episodes on
Sunday June 19th on TV land
welcome to think again thank you thanks
for having me I wanted to start off just
kind of asking you about courage right
like a lot of people in the world seem
to be I would say most people in most
industries seem to be walking around
with various kinds of masks on trying to
protect themselves from looking stupid
and in your work you go to the land of
totally grotesque over-the-top kind of
all of the worst possible insecurities
and reflections that the world might
have on you you put them out there and
like maybe exaggerate them as well do
you feel that that makes you stronger
over time does that help you deal with
those demons is it free therapy I mean
your work is hilariously funny but I'm
interested in your perspective on going
out raw like that I think I think well I
think there's one aspect of courage of
that it's not a decision where you
embrace courage and then you're
courageous like I think I was courageous
to try stand-up comedy right but there
has to be numerous moments where I go
all right now I'm gonna be courageous
and revealed this about myself but that
being said I feel as though there's some
times we attribute courageous behavior
to personality
trait right so there are some people
that are outspoken and Donald Trump yeah
and we think they're courageous right so
I feel like sometimes with comedy people
are like that's brave and you're like
yeah yeah that person is being maybe
they're being brave or they're
manipulating the zeitgeist that we exist
in for their benefit in order to look
brave and get yeah p.m. together to get
a helping to post Arden right right and
so I mean but they might not be
consciously doing that but I think that
as a comedian it should be it's more
important to be funny right now you you
probably need some bravery and going
about being funny I think that some of
like even silly funny there takes a
bravery like you look at Will Ferrell
there's a lot of bravery there yeah yeah
he's doing something that could fall on
its face but there's a bravery in that
silliness that he does right and I think
that's what we enjoy about it cause it I
mean I think it's in you know your
intention obviously is to be funny which
you are but it also is empowering I
think or freeing for other people to
watch somebody go up there and talk
directly about things that most people
are afraid to admit that they even feel
you know right yeah I think well it's
also liberating because I think that we
can't feel all these things all the time
right like the whole concept like we're
all gonna die but we don't really want
to think about it but it is funny for
someone like George Carlin to talk like
here's this chunk on suicide which is
brilliant but it's also we don't want to
think about it we don't want to think
about the fact that right now someone is
getting ready to kill themselves which
is a line from his material so yeah I
think but also I personally think
comedians get a lot of credit and
criticism
what they would do anyway so in
otherwise people might credit me for
being a clean comedian but you know it
hasn't been necessary for us to curse in
this portion of the podcast no we're
gonna I don't get not gonna have to
curse a lot I don't get any credit for
being he was you know what he's really
good and he was clean in the podcast you
know it's strange yeah it's not like we
live in such a cursing filled world well
I mean it is a weird thing in common and
liquid just used to for whatever reason
and my understanding is that like early
in your career like your producers or
whatever we're pressuring you to guess
you actually had to add cursing into the
album is that right like yeah yeah they
were like you know what you might want
to curse more and I'll have a greater
appeal with teenagers yeah and so I was
like all right
I added some curse words but it wasn't
and on the other side it's not as if I
didn't have some curse words when I
first started but I mostly got rid of
them because I didn't feel like it was
that creative right to just say
yeah I mean like and I'd have to remove
it for an appearance on Conan or
Letterman anyway and then I just
realized oh I didn't even finish writing
the joke but then again it's cursing for
Chris Rock is incredibly authentic so I
wouldn't ask him to not turn right
hopefully you're not sitting there well
he had to curse one yeah it's like
people really I mean Oh being from the
Midwest and coming to New York when I
first got a job in advertising right I
was shocked how much people were cursing
I was like aren't we supposed to be
creative here and people were gonna
god damn right
and you're like all right so but
culturally it's a different environment
you know you live in a city you know I
cursed in everyday life but if I'm
talking about fried chicken it's not
necessary no say this is good
yeah yeah my mother's you know opinion
on cursing was always kind of similar to
what you're talking about in terms of
like you can do better than that you can
come up with something more interesting
and like as I've grown older
honestly I just don't care like a lot of
the hip-hop music I listen to
oh yeah they're cursing and and I'm not
like yeah it's antic and but I'm not
like why couldn't you come up no never
no word at that moment you know no no
it's like excuse me Little John is it
Little John or Lil Jon no but I also
feel and it's interesting because it
goes back to the bravery thing having
young children quick story on the
cursing totally is my ten-year-old son
was a cursing and I said to him I go
look I don't care if you curse I really
don't you can curse around me but if you
curse at school you're gonna get in
trouble
so don't curse at school but feel like
you can curse around me and what
happened is all he did was curse around
me and then you would curse around me
while other people were present so it
was just like alright fine
like I tried and other people are like
what is wrong with Jim that he's bowing
yes kid so it's like comes down to like
you know alright fine just don't curse
now I'm dealing with this as well I have
an ear old son and you know we listen to
the soundtrack of Hamilton the musical
and I'm like trying to turn the radio
down at certain moments and you know and
I just finally had a conversation when
he's a smart kid he's a verbal kid I
finally was like look I don't really
understand what it is about these words
maybe cuz they're like on the cusp of
violence or something but we like
regulate them you know they're not okay
everywhere but I want you to be able to
listen to some things that are good
the untrust that you're not gonna run
out in the street and start cursing can
I can we do that and he's like yeah yeah
but we'll see I mean who knows I may
come back to bite me in the butt but the
bravery thing is I mean I don't know if
you encounter this with your cuz being
around children and you know when you're
like when you've been on the planet for
eight years there's a lot more bravery
that you have to engage in that when
you're in your 30s or 40s
oh yeah just getting on the school bus I
mean there's a lot of brave
you have to sit there and go I'm the
brand new experience here so encouraging
my children to be brave has really you
know to not be a hypocrite I have to be
brave right so the parenting thing is
weird it's very strange
I imagine I mean I have another thing
that people always bring up about you of
course is that you have a lot of kids
you have five now I have fine and you
talk about it in your routines and to
judge by the your standup it's like your
home life is this constant like
beleaguered state of exhaustion sort of
thing but I'm sure that's not really it
but it's like there's way more people
that have five kids then make a living
going onstage give me any approval of
strangers so being a parent of five you
know it's chaos but because it is chaos
it's a chaos that enriches your life but
I think it's it's impossible to
articulate it right the benefits without
it sounding like you're trying to sell
some pyramids lifestyle or something you
know you're I mean like it's great I
don't get sleep it's great I'm changing
diapers at 5:40
so the the strange you know like the
parenting thing yeah so we should let
the audience yeah like you guys if you
want to have five kids feel free but
you're not Jim is not absolute izing
here no not wired to do that no it's
very sick another five kids and the
clean comedy yeah they keep they keep
coming up it's like people like five
kids click Maddie are you or a nominee
for the Republican Party you know and
it's just like part of that III want to
say and you know you you also joke like
in your new series there's stuff about
kind of a sense of alienation of the
Midwestern culture in New York and like
people being like you're from no one
knows where you're Wisconsin or yeah and
but you know I also
didn't realize I was Midwestern until I
got here
like when I was growing up I was like
this there's been some misunderstanding
I'm not supposed to be going to parties
in high school sitting on bales of hay
which I mean I didn't do every night
that happened it was actual hey there
was a night in high school where I was
sitting on a bale a head that's like
we're actually at a party in Indiana
where we're sitting on a bale of hay and
there was actually and you know I went
to parties in trailer parks which seemed
foreign to New Yorkers but it wasn't it
wasn't dad odd yeah well I think that's
the really interesting thing is that
like these external aspects of our
culture or whatever that like seems so
shocking or alienating or surprising and
end up can end up being the only three
things that people keep talking about
are there they matter but they don't
matter you know they don't yeah it's
content right right it's similar it goes
back to the you know comedians just want
to be known as funny people can add
female by male they can add
african-american all these things but in
the end it's funny funny or not funny
people are not going to a theater to
watch me do stand-up because I'm not
cursing they're not going because I'm
not cursing right they're going because
it's funny hopefully it is funny and
that's why you're you're there with the
other folks you know yeah Louie CK and
you know you're you're one of those guys
you know well and and Gaus so I think
now let's get to the second part show
where you and I are in the same boat
we're going to watch three surprise
interview clips on any possible so this
is just about me talking out my ass
this is that's exactly what it okay yep
right okay this is Sean Wilentz who's an
American historian and he's talking
about Donald Trump's crisis presidency
would the GOP suspend the Constitution
every time you get one of these
movements and they've been again they've
occurred before in American history
there's always an argument that somehow
somebody has taken America away from
Americans and we're gonna try to bring
it back take it back from them and
restore what was that happened with the
Federalists in 1800 of that the
naturalize unnatural eyes dimma grants
that happened in the 1850s with Irish
and German Catholic immigrants and it's
happening now something terrible has
been taken away and they're trying to
bring it back it's appealing to people's
fears they're appealing to people's
sense that they are no longer they don't
over count but we've seen that before as
well I mean this isn't there's nothing
new about any of this interestingly it's
usually a sign or it's Minnis on of a
political party that's about to crack up
and that certainly happened in 1800 it
happened in the 1850s in 1920s and 30s
the old guard in the Republican Party
that brought back the economics that led
to the Great Depression they too were
being buoyed up by a resurgence of
nativism which led to a law in 1924 that
grossly districted immigration from
abroad in all three cases the parties
either collapsed entirely or they were
marginalized the Republicans didn't
elect a president from Franklin Delano
Roosevelt coming in in 1932 until thirty
years later the president they elected
in 1952 Dwight Eisenhower basically
ratified a new deal consensus so this
greater making America great again
usually means that a party's about to
get get under you know fall under great
pressure it's gonna if not collapse and
tarde Elise is going to disintegrate or
be pushed to the margins
there's something you know I have a
couple things on Trump one is I tend to
be nervous about
the groupthink of people that don't like
Trump which that is a refreshing and
novel opinion I have not heard yes that
I don't like Trump mm-hmm but I get
worried that we are instead of
explaining to people that like Trump
what's wrong with it
right we'd rather be right and we'd
rather say you're an idiot yeah which is
what I think happened when John Kerry
ran against George Bush people with
different opinions are very valid and
what we see is so apparent about Trump
all right
we're being dismissive to the fact that
there's things appealing about drunk
right so someone that does support Trump
like I work on on this show that I want
everyone to watch but yes the Jim
Gaffigan show second season starting
soon it is really funny and you've seen
it I have seen it and I can't say
anything but but the the thing is is
that of the cast and crew no one
admitted to voting or being interested
in Trump no one admitted to it but
someone might must be of course yeah of
course you know and so therefore it
makes me think that there's an absence
of dialogue surrounding this so yeah
this mentality this mob mentality sure
I'm just saying you're an idiot you're
wrong and your ear and validated yeah
that's pretty universal to humans if
they're not really careful about it
because we are sort of pack animals and
we want to make sure that we're cool and
yeah everything's fine and these are
this is my tribe and you know if the
others come we can win you know or
whatever right but um I totally agree
with you that it is dangerous
entirely to dismiss people entirely and
I feel like that is what leads to I mean
also doing things like carpet bombing
the Middle East but but that is one
thing that leads to radicalization and
you know dismissing people in their
worldviews entirely is one thing that
leads to people becoming increasingly
radicalized to the point where they're
like oh yeah I'm an idiot screw you like
right you know it's like by the way
those people like in I believe it was
San Jose that were attacking those Trump
supporters I watched that and I was like
oh my gosh don't you realize that people
that were on the fence are now for Trump
because of that right because people
were attacking these people for having a
different opinion
I mean look Fox News MSNBC I you know
they're two different have dozen the
other right yeah and by the way I enjoy
news I enjoy opinions I enjoy Chris
Matthews I enjoy Greta Van Susteren I
enjoy it but I also think that it's
pretty impossible for a human being to
deliver the news completely without
opinion I think the Internet has also
made us start to question the value of
that pose of objectivity I mean that is
to say there has to be a spectrum I mean
you know everyone shouldn't always be
ranting on oh yeah yeah we the other all
the time
but more transparency about where people
and organization and by the way I think
that I get worried that it's so
fragmented that people only watch them
in MSNBC people only watch Fox people
only read Drudge people only you know
listen to NPR which is everyone's right
but the problem is is that then you turn
on BBC news and you're like what so it's
I mean this is it is commerce right
right and different opinions are really
important so in my other note on Trump
which no one wants to it
is that when we all watched his
acceptance speeches as entertainment
right there were plenty of times that we
kind of nodded along and we don't want
to admit that and it's not the hateful
stuff but the cheerleading high school
football coach that makes Trump
appealing is appealing he's really good
at that like if you're my bro
then I'll go the mile for you you know
we're together like we're great and
you're a great you know and there's also
this game of telephone that occurs in
the conversation about Trump calling him
a racist all he has to do is speak and
not be racist and it discredits that
argument right it's like putting labels
on someone that you disagree with I mean
I don't want to say that it's hyperbolic
but it's like saying that he's
unqualified to be President is different
than saying he's a monster
sure if you say he's a monster and
people watch him and he's not a monster
it discredits your argument and so I
also think that discrediting these
people that do support him look I'm from
Indiana I live in Manhattan
I've auditioned for shows in LA that
portray the Midwest in small-town
America in an insulting way yeah so I
understand the mentality of the anti
elitism I understand it I understand
that you know people saying that people
that believe in God are idiots
I find that hurtful even if someone
doesn't go to church their grandpa does
right so you're attacking my grandpa
that's right so then I'm not on your
team dear I mean yeah no I want to go I
want to go there for a second like I cuz
yeah cuz my grandmother my mom's mother
was religious
they were there Italian Roman Catholic
my mom religious and my dad's side
atheists humanists Jews um but my
grandmother my mom's mother I would have
convert long conversations with her
about her beliefs and but I realized in
myself that like over time since then
you know having lived in New York all
these years I've grown more and more I I
mean I don't think I'd be coming out on
social media saying disparaging and
stupid things about the Midwest but I've
become more and more alienated from the
idea of religious people and what you
said is a it's kind of a wake-up call
like to think about you know you know I
mean it's it's a form of bigotry right
right and we all have different shades
of it like you know yeah we we all have
sexism too it's like we can be the most
liberal guy and there's still sexist
thoughts there I mean it's like we don't
we don't have it figured out I think we
should hear someone out do you know the
people that support Trump are not idiots
they're not I mean some of them may be
but no but but wait what is an idiot
well that's one it yeah right right
what is an idiot so no that's a very
nice I was joking but you're but from
our view boy you know being New Yorkers
and probably I don't know if you grew up
in New York but like DC VRC but East
Coast but you know I've been in New York
for 25 years Trump has been in
newspapers for 25 years
yeah and part of you know what I
understand of America the business
mentality Trump makes all the sense in
the world
sure do you I mean it's like yeah yeah
seems he's successful he's yes I mean I
mean no I know there's fewer times
articles that are like by the way is not
right right but but yeah I know what I'm
saying is facts or perception aside it
has to be a dialogue because it's like
we're constantly being manipulated to by
serial or you know support this or that
I just think that like you know the
Trump Elizabeth Warren Twitter war is
like I mean I admire part of it but I
also think is that productive and by the
way I also sit there and then I question
that and I go maybe we need to do every
resource in the world and maybe she's
doing the best service but I also feel
like I don't know if the Twitter dialog
is the platform I mean by the way can I
also bring up so of course you can yeah
so this is I have five young children
well my oldest is 12
they hate Trump they hate him
do not point anything you've said that
guys not from anything I've said yeah
but you know they've had discussions you
know during the primaries like are we
Bernie people or are we Hillary people
and I'd have a discussion with them
about it and it's interesting as a
parent to see where did they get that
where did they get that right some of it
is seeing vines where people are making
fun of Trump - okay but and it makes me
nervous because it's just like there's
this impressionable side and then there
is this human resistance to being told
what to do so it's like when I was a kid
Sylvester Stallone was the biggest thing
in the world and then collectively we
decided that we didn't like him and that
happened with Anne Hathaway
for no reason at all people just decided
hey everyone we're done she's not cool
anymore for no reason at all I don't
know maybe there was some reason but
it's just so like the group mentality
that I see my children who are very
bright and you know they they know that
Trump wants to build a wall and that's
why I said disparaging things about
immigrants and stuff like that but like
it makes me it just it worries me how
impressionable we are I know I know it
was a trip for me when I realized you
know at some point in high school that
like the alienated all black clothing
goth look that I had cultivated was
actually totally conformist
yeah within my alienated subculture you
know which I thought was so radical in
fighting the man and whatever
wellhere's it's like you know I'm this
kind of everyman right and sure my
outfit in doing stand-up I wanted to be
very plain not have a draw any attention
I had friends that were dressing like
rock stars I had friends that were
embracing the latest trends I was always
jeans and a shirt and I gave myself
credit for not doing anything but that
in not choosing I was making a choice
that's a look yeah I mean yeah yeah it's
like you can't you are participating by
not participating right yeah now they
call it normcore whatever it's just like
you can't dodge it yeah so yeah I don't
know but at least we can be maybe aware
of it yeah
or try right yeah okay so let's see what
the next one yeah we have a cool
we that we we got pretty deep into that
one this is Dan Pontefract future of
work envision ER and it is called forget
work-life balance achieve work-life
integration by finding purpose well
that's interesting especially since your
work integrates our life okay cool let's
see
famous Danish philosopher sren
kierkegaard once wrote to be that self
which one truly is is something to first
think about when you're trying to figure
out your own personal purpose so the
three questions I want you to think
about are as follows what are you about
the second one is Who am I Who am I
trying to be and then the last question
is how how am I going to show up each
and every day in this life of mine once
you begin defining deciding and
developing your what your who and your
how at the end of the day that's going
to create a pathway to purpose purpose
is not given to you purpose is defined
and decided and developed by you now
ostensibly we all have to work somewhere
and so what you're trying to do is to
match as best possible that defines
sense of self with an organization that
ideally has as close a match to that
defined sense of self so you're looking
for an organization that also has
defined itself and ultimately both you
and the organization are then in the
sweet spot
what I enjoyed about what that guy that
guy dan dan Pontefract yeah what I
enjoyed what he said which is something
that informs me as a father and also as
you know a comedian and a human being is
I've such gratitude for the fact that
what I do for a living is something I
enjoy
so it's interesting I thought that video
was gonna be more about like love what
you do and but I such gratitude for
having the occupation that I like right
and having a clarity of the point of
view of not only my comedy but what kind
of ideas are presenting right which
leads to this other thing which is it's
an imperfect idea but as a comedian
again I believe people do what they want
there's no incredible calculation in
stand-up comedy but there is something
about bringing light to the world versus
bringing darkness short meaning we all
have friends and we all have times where
we bitch and moan or we have a friend
who's very bitchy and is mean and we
laugh but afterwards there's a bit of a
hangover associated with it yeah there's
an ickiness yeah now when you bring
light in a creative endeavor it becomes
evergreen so in other words complaining
about something is never as potent as an
observation which is universal to the
human experience right so of course and
to put a asterisk to that I mean you
know in the case of say Woody Allen's
early stand-up or he could complain but
in such a precise and observational way
that it did become and by the right
Richard Pryor was very much doing that
right it's why but the thing is is that
it's
also a different thing but topical
comedy say a monologue joke verses like
a Mitch Hedberg joke right Mitch Hedberg
jokes are gonna be around in 20 years
whereas we don't remember Letterman or
Leno's monologue jokes right and so the
insight of an observational joke or
something about the human experience or
Richard Pryor revealing aspects of his
insecurities is bringing light does that
make sense yeah it makes a lot of sense
and so that's you know when he talks
about purpose it's something that I
remember I had this is back when I had
like a VHS of a tape and I gave it to
someone of my standup 20 years ago and
the guy said it's funny but it's a
little mean it's mean models interesting
and it was me two models and so you were
taking kind of like an easy road they're
like yes I mean at that it's similar to
how you might look at jokes that were
funny and in the 90s and be like wow
that's that's pretty mean two midgets
that's be mean to this person or
whatever why would they do that yeah you
know like put down humor is the easiest
most accessible thing but it's very base
it's very simple yeah and by the way
there can become robbery with it you
with your friends you give each other
very fun right but it's almost kind
of a sarcastic take on insults oh yeah
right exactly there's some meta
awareness right you guys are all screwed
it's like we're all friends here and I'm
making fun of you for this but me
identifying that I have knowledge of you
and I know that you know that I'm making
fun of it and that you're gonna take it
well and not be better and so on yeah
and so the the reason I bring up those
jokes were I was making in front of the
model and it doesn't have to be perfect
is that he
was right he was right I was bagging on
models and I call it kind of us and them
which is not different from a polish
joke
it goes back you know yeah as you were
talking I was thinking that like the
bringing of lighting because it's a
subtle thing it's not always obvious
unless you sort of know what you're
looking to feel from it like you know
cuz for example there were plenty of
people in America who freaked out when
the Simpsons came out like oh my god
it's destroying American values blah
blah blah but the fact is that the
Simpsons was nothing but love for
Humanity as like and and I think that
that's you know also going back to what
we were saying earlier to bring this
full circle before we kind of close it
up to having dialogue with people who
think differently from you like about
Trump bringing light into the world is
about having some sense of the bigger
picture and belonging to it as a breath
to try and I think even even when we
shoot you know like Seinfeld show like
that they were like the only rule is no
hugs right right because that's that's
just like a clumsy theatrical device
people hug you know it's right I get it
but that being said when Jeannie and I
do our show and actually our DP Neil's
Alpert who is great we have these
conversations of where is the love in
this moment or in this scene or in this
episode because as human beings even
someone you have a contentious
relationship with right there is
something there like my character and
Michael Ian Black Scare achter right
very much there is but they love each
other because of the sarcastic barbs
right that they throw at each other it's
very whole ding them together there but
I think that's a very important element
things that you that we like the show
Seinfeld or The Simpsons the reason we
like that is and even on the family
they're in the element there is this you
know meathead and Archie Bunker there is
an affection there and there's a
patience behind that which spoke volumes
to that
generation right yeah which is what
family can do right because nobody is
saying I mean unless somebody says screw
you forever moves out like nobody's
saying that and all which is the Irish
way yeah like and all in the family
you're trapped
you know like you're drunk you're there
so you got to deal with these which is
you know it's just an exaggerated
example of what happens in every family
right right which potentially ideally is
a microcosm of understanding as
ultimately as opposed to
misunderstanding right now right as long
as nobody says if we get you forever
all right right which is by the way in
some ways even saying that to someone is
expressing that they're important to you
right yeah I mean well sadly if you want
to be a real jerk don't leave right I
mean this is that's what the
pathological side of my brain where I'm
on you you know you want to make a
statement just I mean that's it'll look
good like a joke and my friend Tom
Schiller has this joke where it's like
Italians will argue and make up like
five times a meal and the Irish
Catholics will like carry a simple
grudge to a funeral right they're like
I'll forgive you at the funeral
you know so Jim Gaffigan this has been
great thank you thank you or spending
thank you and think again I've really
enjoyed our common fun and that's it for
this week's episode of think again next
week it's fourth of July weekend I hope
you all have exciting plans that don't
involve sitting in traffic for very long
we have a really great episode coming up
on Saturday but you can of course wait
until Monday or Tuesday to listen if
you're having a great time with your
family it's Sean Wilentz he's a
Princeton historian the author of a new
book about partisanship in America which
apparently has been with us forever and
he argues that it's actually good for
the American people which is definitely
an interesting perspective it's a really
really good conversation Sean is also
the official historian of Bob Dylan for
his website for Chicago fans of the show
or anyone near Chicago I want to let you
on July 6th I'll be giving a free talk
at podcast movement which is a
podcasting conference
it's a PMX talk which is billed as a
ted-like talk for the podcasting
community I'm going to be talking about
my experience in developing the show and
learning to work with and talk with all
of these fascinating guests it's gonna
be at around 11:25 a.m. on Wednesday
July 6 I hope to see you then check out
podcast movement PMX
talks on Google
you